Sometimes in the political world, when you
are an exception to the rule, you get a lot
of attention and oftentimes that attention
can become weaponized.
For example, most black Americans are pretty
liberal.
So when someone like Candace Owens or right
wing black woman, supposedly right wing, I
mean I think it's partially a character she
plays, but whatever she presents us right
wing, she gets attention, she gets a ton of
attention and is able to spread dangerous
misinformation, which is welcomed with open
arms by right-wingers.
Most American Jews are liberal.
So when you have a conservative Jew, they
often get more attention for their views than
they would if their identity was different.
And another example of this is that Hollywood
and actors are overwhelmingly liberal.
So when someone like James Woods, the actor
who's a right winger starts sharing right-wing
talking points, he gets more attention because
partially of his identity, and this is very
dangerous.
The same applies to college kids and people
just out of college or people who would be
just out of college if they went but maybe
didn't, uh, who tend to be more on the left.
So when someone like Charlie Kirk is out there,
they get a lot of attention and they can spread
very dangerous disinformation.
And case in point over the weekend, James
Woods and Charlie Kirk both shared a suppose
it analysis and using that term is almost
a joke of how Bernie Sanders would handle
taxes and paying for Medicare for all.
And it is riddled with not differences, opinion,
which are fine.
It's just riddled with this information.
And unfortunately the posts caught fire.
The Trump is love it.
These have been shared hundreds of thousands
of times across all the people who have posted
them.
The graphic that James Woods and Charlie Kirk
shared claims that since under a Bernie Sanders
administration, everybody gets at least 15
bucks an hour for work that they do.
Uh, anybody working full time.
Of course not taking any time off would earn
$31,200 a year at a minimum, and the graphic
that's being being shared goes on to say,
Bernie is going to pay for Medicare for all
by taxing people making over 29,000 at the
rate of 52%.
Now this is completely wrong, but according
to this viral image that makes the effective
after tax, hourly wage of someone getting
paid 15 bucks an hour and paying 52% in taxes,
which of course is a lie, they end up only
taking home $7 and 20 cents an hour.
Charlie Kirk shared the same thing with the
additional message.
Socialism sucks added to the bottom.
Now it's actually difficult to know where
to start with this, but it's a good opportunity
to really get a good understanding of how,
how Bernie's plan would work, how Bernie's
tax plan would work, how we'd pay for Medicare
for all.
Now we can have reasonable fact-based disagreements
about Bernie's Medicare for all plan.
For example.
You could argue, I don't believe it's fair
to rich people to do what Bernie wants to
do.
Okay.
We could debate that.
That's a great conversation.
You could say, I don't think it's fair to
poor people or middle-class people.
You could say, I think Bernie is too optimistic
and how cheap the delivery of healthcare will
be under his plan.
Great.
I've made that critique.
We can talk about it, but we have to be arguing
about the real world.
We can't be arguing about these completely
fake disagreements based on viral right-wing
dis information.
So let's dig into it.
First of all, our tax rates are marginal.
Number one, meaning you only pay the highest
rate on income, uh, for the money earned above
where that bracket starts.
So in Bernie's tax brackets, a single taxpayer
would pay 52% tax only on income above $10
million a year.
So someone earning the $31,200 mentioned in
this viral image would pay 10% on their first
9,500 bucks and then 12% on the amount they
make between 95 25 and 31,200 now remember
that there is a standard deduction of $12,200
which would drop the taxable income for someone
earning 31 to two just $19,000 which means
they'd end up paying a little over $2,000
in taxes.
They would then get their additional 4% for
healthcare on their income based premium that
Bernie has proposed.
And this means if you earn 31 two you end
up with an effective tax rate of 9.1% not
52% and that includes your payment towards
healthcare.
Imagine being this financially illiterate
and still having a voice in the political
discussion like James Woods or Charlie Kirk
and the disinformation being spread argues
that all sorts of people would be paying 52%
tax when in reality the 52% applies only to
incomes above $10 million per year.
In 2014 that would have applied to only 0.02%
of taxpayers.
That number presumably is a little bit higher
in 2020 so there's plenty to debate about
Medicare for all you need.
The Senate support AOC recently said, Bernie
can't wave a magic wand and make Medicare
for all happen.
I said it months ago, I was crushed for it.
AOC said it, she was welcomed mostly with
open arms, but she's right and it's a very
real question about Medicare for all.
I believe Bernie's plan understates the cost
of care, but Bernie doesn't want people earning
$31,000 to pay 52% income of their income
to taxes.
And they are either fundamentally ignorant
to the reality of the plan.
That's one possibility.
They just don't get it or they know that they
can't actually argue against the plan on its
merits, so they resort to spreading disinformation
and it works because these bogus numbers were
shared hundreds of thousands of times by the
various people that posted and re posted and
retweeted them.
We can't let them control the information
in this way because they are weaponizing the,
call it ignorance, call it gullibility,
call it whatever you want.
It is being weaponized by the American, right,
very successfully.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
D Pacman.
We'll be back right after this